you
have had
a
vaccine injury is it fair to say that
yes it is
all right and i will say uh i have
suffered the accusation of being an
anti-vaxxer which is a preposterous
accusation in my on my uh in my case for
a number of reasons i'm one highly
vaccinated against a wide range of
things some of them
rather exotic and two i'm also a big fan
of the idea of vaccination i think it is
incredibly elegant that we can inform
the immune system about pathogens that
we have not encountered and no ancestor
of ours has encountered so that it will
get the jump on those things when we do
encounter them this is a beautiful
system and i in no way am opposed to us
wielding it to the medical benefit of
people or to the epidemiological benefit
of society now i also know you can't
possibly be an anti-vaxxer either
because you wouldn't have a vaccine
injury if you had been one because you
wouldn't have gotten vaccinated is that
a fair characterization
right and also i uh wasn't in any way
required to that's the other thing i
don't work outside the home so i suppose
you could have someone who was an
anti-vaxxer and had their arms twisted
but that wasn't the case i just went out
and decided to do it in my case
yes i very nearly uh got vaccinated too
i did not because i was concerned that
there were risks that we obviously
couldn't rule out early in the process
and so in effect i was delaying
vaccination in order to know more about
what happened to people who were
vaccinated and the more i heard the more
alarmed i became
um but i'm not an anti-vaxxer you're not
an anti-vaxxer and uh
when did you get your your vaccination
april 14th april 14th and which one did
you get it was pfizer um first dose
first dose and did you
uh have your reaction to the first dose
or did you get a second i only got the
first dose i
had my adverse event in response to that
first dose and
definitely did not want the second one
all right and what was your reaction
so that very night i just i started
getting some allergic
symptoms itching ears and head
and then um within
and then and that was at the same time
as the expected things fatigue and that
sort of thing that everybody thought
within those couple of first days i
started getting nerve pains and
if you've ever had nerve pains they're
very distinctive they're a zinging
feeling and i would get those in
different places in my body
um i was a little worried um
i thought maybe the shingles that i had
had the previous year was coming back
but it never developed
like shingles over the next couple of
weeks i kept having those i would call
them sort of wandering nerve pains
but i didn't get too worried until about
three weeks later when it just
it revved its zinged way up to extreme
pain um in my back and my uh
tailbone and buttocks and legs my legs
started feeling very heavy
um all kinds of things many different
places zinging in my eyes and my face
and
paresthesia in my face and that kind of
thing
and um
basically to make a long story short the
doctors are baffled uh i'm just taking
gabapentin for nerve pain at this point
which is not uh therapeutic it's just
for the pain and it's been seven months
and nobody's found any effective
treatment and my symptoms just kind of
go up and down and up and down and up
and down and i have a terrific amount of
pain and nobody seems to have a solution
so i'll keep that i'll keep it bad short
um there are other symptoms as well but
i don't want to make the list too long i
do have tinnitus which is somewhat
recognized so maybe some people will
recognize that too just to show the
variety of symptoms involved
yeah i've heard terrifying stories of
tinnitus
beyond
what a human being can tolerate it's
really an incredibly frightening thing i
have a certain amount of uh tinnitus and
i must say most of the time i don't even
realize it's there unless i listen for
it um but a tinnitus that's absolutely
unignorable i've heard comparisons to
and mine is not
my worst symptom but it's you know when
the other symptoms zoom up that kind of
zooms up too so
all right now let's um be cautious here
obviously there is some possibility
that what we have is mere coincidence
that something medically anomalous
happened to you and that the coincidence
and time of it following your
vaccination
is not causal but it seems so because
we humans for very easily understood
adaptive reasons are always looking for
connections because very frequently we
find them they are real and we can make
use of them um what what can you tell us
about the
possibility that what you're dealing
with is an unfortunate medical situation
that doesn't have anything to do with
the vaccination you got
in my in my own case i just i think
that's particularly unlikely for several
reasons first of all my complete
good health right up until i i went in
and we were even joking about things
like oh maybe you're gonna grow another
head or whatever you know i mean i
wasn't anxious or anything like that
secondly the fact that the initial
symptoms did come on
along with
the expected symptoms and within that
expected 48-hour um time window when you
do expect to get um
side effects and everybody expects to
get side effects and then it seemed to
grow
out of that and then thirdly what i
imagine we'll we'll talk about more
which is the similarity to other side
effects that i have only subsequently
learned about that other people have had
so uh all right
what was your experience um in terms you
know so you had this event you got a
vaccination that you believed was
safe enough to be
uh worth taking and uh effective enough
it's something we both agree is
dangerous coveted
that you went and got it and then you
started having reactions some of them
within the range of normal
many of them not within the range of
normal and alarming what did you do next
uh you go to doctor after doctor after
doctor yeah i got in touch with my
primary care doctor i kept her you know
very informed she was very concerned at
first she urged me to get the second
vaccine but when um things got bad
enough she kind of stopped you know
pushing that um you research you get
online you google you try to figure out
what to do i kept
you know a lot of records of my symptoms
uh especially in like my my messages on
the uh the my chart portal to my doctor
oh this new thing has happened this new
thing has happened um also we tried um
we tried
valtrex which is a anti-viral medication
in case it was
uh shingles coming back and so we tried
to get right on that that didn't help
and then the other thing we tried was
prednisone which is an anti-inflammatory
pretty standard anti-inflammatory that
didn't seem to be helping and then later
i had a second round of that at a much
higher dose that actually seemed to make
matters worse for reasons unknown so you
know we did try some reasonable things
um and after that all you can do is keep
making appointments with new specialists
to see if they'll have any additional
ideas
was there agreement amongst the doctors
that you saw that what you were dealing
with was a reaction to the vaccine
um
my my pcp seemed to think so she and i
both at first thought maybe it was the
shingles because we had heard of
shingles being uh that was like a known
thing that sometimes it brought it back
up but then when there were no lesions
and it didn't stay in one place on one
side of the body then we weren't sure
what to do the um first
immunologist i saw
immediately agreed that it was and in
fact he said verbally to me
this is why we usually test these
for two to three years
because of autoimmune disorders that can
arise um
i've had one neurologist also say it i i
found that other other doctors will tend
to just record that that's what i said
and not necessarily give me a strong
opinion
one way or another i mean i've been
lucky that nobody said you're totally
crazy um but i don't want to say that
they've all just spontaneously happily
agreed that it's what it is i think
there's a certain amount of caution
all right um
you had an immunologist tell you that
as he saw it this did appear to be a
reaction to the vaccine i will say one
of the things that alarmed me was that
given that we couldn't possibly have had
any information on the long-term effects
of these things that we were portraying
them as safe which anything that
interacts with the immune system
and for which we don't have any
long-term information about what has
happened to people who've taken it can't
really be safe because its whole purpose
is to modify
this fundamental system and you know we
have
allergic disorders we have autoimmunity
there are many ways in which that system
can be disrupted in a very negative way
um so anyway interesting to hear that an
immunologist
uh saw this as
quite uh quite likely to be causal
all right
so in addition to the doctors that you
saw
um did you encounter others who
had similar stories so at first i i
didn't
you know i i thought of myself as kind
of a unicorn and my family of course you
know all believe me they were appalled
but um other immediate members of my
family didn't have a problem so i kept
hearing you know safe safe safe rare
rare rare so i thought well i guess i
must just be one of those really really
rare things
um and i forget what first prompted me
to
be it was just in all the googling i was
doing i came across the story of a girl
a young girl named maddie d guerrae
um who is
now 13 she was 12 she was in the pfizer
trial for 12 to 15 year olds now she is
in a wheelchair but
various of her symptoms
were similar enough to mine only more
extreme
that i said oh
you know maybe there are more people out
there so i began uh looking a little
further and eventually got
connected with a couple of facebook
groups that are uh you know documenting
these things and bringing people
together who all claim to have been uh
vaccine injured by these vaccines and i
was just i was just astounded
by the the similarity
so let's let's let's come back to that
in a second i do want to point out a
couple of things about uh the maddie
degare story that are that are worth
mentioning
first off
she's very severely injured she's in a
wheelchair i think you said as far as we
know she will require one for the rest
of her life she's also on a feeding tube
this is a previously healthy
child
in the trial itself my understanding
is that her
symptoms caused them to quote unquote
unblind the study that is to reveal that
she got the vaccine rather than the
placebo
immediately ostensibly so that she could
be
properly treated but what this did
was it had effects again this is my
understanding from others it had effects
on the continuing of the collection of
data so she was recorded as having had
stomach upset
when in fact she is crippled and now
requiring of a feeding tube and
uh and a wheelchair and so in some sense
this is yes an anecdote it's one
individual and again there is a remote
possibility that something simply
coincidental could explain this on the
other hand healthy children don't
suddenly end up in wheelchairs and
needing field to feeding tubes very
frequently this is an extremely
rare event and when we say well the
trials showed these things to be safe
that depends on the trials having been
well done it depends on things like us
continuing to track people whose story
does not suggest that they had a smooth
ride and maddie diges case says exactly
the opposite it says that there are
things that we should know that are not
widely known
all right now you said you found
a facebook group or several a couple a
couple of them i was going to mention
too that if you look up that pfizer 12
to 15 uh year old trial
you will not find it easy to to find it
mentioned that there was even a single
child
who had an adverse event this extreme
and adverse events don't have to be
designated necessarily as causal they're
just supposed to be recorded when you do
a trial you just record your adverse
events among the test group and your
adverse events among the placebo group
and then the idea is you know you
compare and see if there's a
statistically significant difference uh
you're not supposed to just make up your
mind ahead of time well this wasn't cost
so we're not going to talk to people
about it and i actually had someone whom
i mentioned maddie who went and she went
and looked it up and she said well i
wonder if her parents are just
completely faking this because i can't
find any mention of this uh in the
pfizer trial and i'm like well that's
pretty creepy
you know because if nothing else
there's nobody who's questioning that
she was in the pfizer trial right
and so
you should at least be able to find it
mentioned somewhere other than fox news
that there was a child who was in the
pfizer trial and these events happened
while she was in the pfizer trial right
so it's really striking this gets to
questions of epistemology because at
some level let's let's
give uh i won't even call it the benefit
of the doubt because i think it
stretches a good bit beyond that but
let's bend over backwards to imagine
that this is actually not a meaningful
event in some way
all right
it is still important that
one child
had a serious medical mishap
shortly after being vaccinated even if
these things were unconnected it is
important that that data point land
correctly so that we can begin to detect
a pattern should it emerge
if what we do is we behave in such a way
that that data point
vanishes
and i you know she's not really an
anecdote she was a data point she was in
the trial it was in the trial that's how
you do trials to the extent that that
data point doesn't show up because
it was recorded early as a
stomach upset maybe at the point that it
plausibly was but then it developed into
a crippling injury and that happened oh
yes after the trial had been unblinded
that is no reason not to maintain that
piece of evidence so that we can look at
it later if others who were in the trial
for example show up with a similar set
of symptoms if we disappear that data
point even if we think we're doing the
right thing we have made it impossible
for us to recover the pattern later
should we need to i hope that i am wrong
as far as the prevalence of really bad
side effects among children i would love
for it to be the case that just as
children don't get coveted as badly as a
lot of adults they maybe will also not
get
side effects as badly as adults i don't
think we can infer
the one from the other at all it doesn't
seem to me medically um so i hope we
don't get some explosion but in a dark
way a very dark way it will be
interesting to see what happens if we
start getting a very large number of
anecdotes of
children ages 5 through 11 having
terrible terrible side effects and the
medical establishment saying
i can't hear you or the government
establishment saying i can't hear you is
that going to change anything is
anything going to happen uh to to make
them change course i don't know well
unfortunately i think uh
the maddie de gray story
uh it's a bad sign isn't it it's a it's
an awful sign and i would also say
that no matter what
we are again in the same circumstance
where you can tell
we have no reason to believe that
vaccinating these children is safe it
doesn't mean it will be harmful but it
means that we cannot rule out that it
will be harmful and there are signs that
mean that we should be very concerned
and because healthy children are not
severely harmed by kovid it is a
preposterous it is an evil choice for us
to be making and the fact that
after
ignoring a large group of people who
appears to have been injured by vaccines
that they were told were safe and
effective at seeing that not only has
the have these vaccines failed with
regard to safety but they also have
failed with respect to effectiveness the
fact that we're talking about boosters
being necessary for people six years six
months down the road this tells us that
safe and effective didn't turn out to be
right and the people who assured us that
that was true either knew better and
lied or they didn't know better and
should have or they were caught by
surprise and now they're going to just
double down and say well then i guess we
just got to do it i guess my point would
be though
it's not doubling down when you add
children to the mix
right that is ratcheting up that is a
new level of indifference to potential
harm
and it will be i fear indifference to
actual harm the other thing that strikes
me and
maybe has a little bit of an echo of the
of communism and i hesitate to use this
word but you'll see where i'm going with
it in a minute
is that
the the dig arrays were so pro-vax that
they entered three of their children
into the trial maddie volunteered from
the the story that i've heard is the two
of her siblings were going to be in the
trial and they apparently were fine and
then she said oh i want to help too
because i want to help to end the
pandemic and her parents were thrilled
to let her do it and then this happened
and her parents are like oh my goodness
this happened to us and the fact that
they were so committed to the system was
not good enough to get them listened to
okay and so i think we find that where
we have people who've been sort of
mugged by reality and they're loudly
they were loudly an affirmation of the
system um
like people who were like you know i'm
i'm a good soviet comrade please listen
to me our food supply system is not
working or whatever i'm trying to help
the party right
and then it was like we don't want to
hear what you're saying shut up you know
so it's
the odd thing is you would maybe have
thought that the depth of commitment
that this family had to
the vaccination efforts even for kovitz
specifically would have won them a
hearing but it did not
it's a terrifying
terrifying point
right these are people
who more than did their part
right
and if anyone is deserving of
being
listened to
being treated at the highest possible
level being heralded as a hero i mean if
anybody is a hero of this pandemic this
little girl is she volunteered to test a
vaccine so that panda so the pandemic
could be ended was injured right this is
a this is a
this is a fallen soldier at some level
how dare we how dare we ignore her
that's
it you know
it's a very upsetting point i had not
thought about it that way but
my god
[Music]
you